this is where Marc Thiessen spends his
vacation for me it's an adventure all
your senses just come alive when you're
in the middle of photographing fire and
this is where he makes his living I have
about the least glamorous job as
photographer at Geographic I spend most
of my time photographing artifacts like
dinosaur bones fossils portraits of
people advertisements I don't go chasing
lions and tigers and grizzly bears
instead mark chases wild fires and he
spent a lifetime doing it so during
every summer vacation mark heads out
west to shoot wildland fires
first stop this time is Idaho on this
night mark gets lucky he rides along
through a raging burn sweeping across
the Idaho desert one of the reasons I
was drawn to wildland fire is that you
never know what's gonna happen next and
that's what can make it so fascinating
but that's also it can make it so
dangerous
the wind is just rushing and blowing
sagebrush stumps right past our truck in
this kind of shower of sparks and it's
night and it can be very disorienting
plane that's just coming our direction
so we don't want to be there very long
because some incredible fire behavior
off to our left you see a fire world or
some of the flames start to twirl
together and they start to twist and
then you get this 30 40 foot tall fire
tornado mark is trained and certified as
a wildland firefighter himself he has
made it his personal project to capture
on film the extraordinary men and women
who braved the frontlines there's great
people to meet who have great stories to
tell and great pictures to be taken once
you get on the inside with the other
fire crew people you become one of them
you can become a part of them they don't
really pay much attention to because
they've got such an important job to do
I'm trying to make sense of all this
chaos I'm trying to get a lay of the
land and the terrain and to figure out
where I can get good shots it is that
thrill of seeing and photographing
something so primal so exceptional that
lures Marc Thiessen back each and every
summer when I'm leaving that fire I'm
exhilarated I'm exhausted
I've got adrenaline running through my
veins and I feel like it really lived so
I'm gonna be doing this easily for the
next 20 years as long as I can